>> Todd: ELON MUSK CLEANING
HOUSE AT TWITTER HEADQUARTER
LITERALLY.
HE'S HOLDING AUCTION PUTTING
EXPENSIVE ITEMS FROM THE SAN
FRANCISCO HEADQUARTER UP FOR
BID.
THE COMPANY BEHIND ON RENT.
SOME ITEMS, THAT GIANT TWITTER
BIRD STATUE AND $20,000 ESPRESSO
MACHINE.
BIDS STARTING AT $20.
>> Carley: JIMMY FAILLA JOINS
US, TAKE A STAB AT THIS ONE.
>> Jimmy: THE ELON MUSK STORY?
IF YOU LOOK AT THE THEME OF
THIS, NOBODY AT TWITTER WAS
WORKING, ESPRESSO MACHINE, A
VEGETABLE DRYER.
>> Carley: I JUST ASKED WHAT WAS
A VEGETABLE DRYER --
>> Jimmy: WE DIDN'T HAVE A DRYER
FOR CLOTHES, LET ALONE OUR
YELLOW PEPPERS, THESE WERE
PAMPERED PEOPLE, OPERATING
OVERHEAD HAD GOTTEN TOO MUCH TO
BEAR AND GUY LIKE ELON MUSK, I'M
STARTING A GO FUND ME.
THEY ARE SELLING THE CLOTHES, IF
THEY DON'T SELL THEM, THEY GIVE
THEM AWAY AND THEY WIND UP IN A
THIRD WORLD COUNTRY.
>> Todd: WHY DOES A WORK PLACE,
RHETORICAL QUESTION, HAVE A
VEGETABLE DRYER AND A BRAISING
PAN IN THE FIRST PLACE?
>> Jimmy: IT IS A WOKE DAYCARE.
>> Carley: DID YOU SEE THE
TWITTER EMPLOYEE, FILMED DAY IN
THE LIFE OF TWITTER EMPLOYEE, I
START BY GETTING AN ESPRESSO AND
GO TO THE PING-PONG MACHINE, AND
MEET MY FRIENDS FOR A GAME OF
BOCCE BALL.
>> Jimmy: LIKE SWEET PICKLES, IT
IS NOT A JOB.
>> Todd: YOU WON THE DAY BY
REFERENCING SWEET PICKLES.
"NEW YORK TIMES" 93 MOST STYLISH
PEOPLE OF 2022, INCLUDED ON THE
LIST, NOT MAKING IT UP, SENATOR
ELECT JOHN FETTERMAN, ERIC
S
ADAMS.
THEY ARE GETTING ATTENTION WITH
THIS NONSENSE, THAT IS ALL THEY
WANT, RIGHT?
>> Jimmy: THIS IS AN EMPOWERING
MOMENT, IF JOHN FETTERMAN IS ONE
OF THE BEST DRESSED AMERICANS,
SO IS THE GUY I GAVE A $1 TO ON
THE SUBWAY.
>> Carley: "NEW YORK TIMES" SAYS
THE REASON THEY CHOSE HIM, HE'S
BRINGING CARHART TO THE CAPITOL.
>> Jimmy: DEMOCRAT AND CARHART
IS BEST DRESSED, A REPUBLICAN IN
CARHART WOULD BE WHITE TRASH,
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
AND IANA PRESLEY WAS THREATENING
TO DEFUND THE FASHION POLICE.
YOU'RE IN, WE DON'T WANT
TROUBLE.
>> Carley: DICTIONARY
CONTROVERSY FOR CAMBRIDGE, THEY
DEFINE WOMAN AS ADULT WHO LIVES
AND IDENTIFIES AS FEMALE, THOUGH
MAY HAVE BEEN SAID TO HAVE
DIFFERENT SEX AT BIRTH AND
DEFINITION FOR MAN FOLLOWS ALONG
THE SAME.
KIDS LOOK UP DEFINITION OF WOMAN
AND MAN, THIS IS WHAT WILL POP
UP.
>> Jimmy: THIS IS CAVE TO THE
VERNACULAR.
THIS IS WEAKNESS AND KEY CAVEAT,
THEY SAY ADULT, IF IT IS AN
ADULT WHO IDENTIFIES AS THIS OR
THAT, WHY ARE WE ALLOWING
CHILDREN AND YOUNG TEENS TO
PURSUE HORMONE BLOCKERS AND
OTHER THINGS, IT IS SAYING IF
YOU ARE A KID DOING THIS STUFF,
THIS IS -- YOU ARE A WEEKEND
WARRIOR.
I IDENTIFY AS SOBER.
>> Todd: THE JIMMY OF 10 YEARS
AGO, MAN VERSUS WOMAN WOULD BE
CONTROVERSIAL, OPEN TO DEBATE
AND YOU WOULD BE DISCUSSING THAT
ON NATIONAL TV?
THINK ABOUT THAT.
>> Jimmy: CAN'T TAKE IT,
SLIPPERY SLOPE INTO POP CULTURE,
YOU ARE WATCHING HALL AND OATS
SAYING THEM EATER.
>> Carley: YOU ARE BEST-DRESSED
MAN IN THE BUILDING.
>> Jimmy: FORT WORTH I'M COMING
FO